I remember a day when you were embracing a tear of thought, praying to
God in your chest and hoping for His mercy to flow, so the heart lived with
sincerity and you began to hover like a bird, flying in
cultures and drinking from my Lord
[music]
goodness tom let me tell you something
amazing about quan I told you last you
didn't believe me  you're not going to
start this again are you bro trust me i
you ser quran has a scientific miracle i
told you but didn't believe me so i was
y yesterday i was studing and i found
know what i found guess what quran says
there seven o lers seven seven yeah are
you having a love why it's five don't
you know
this listen to me i just
yesterday setting myself bro are you
talking
did sorry to break you guys up but i
check the nasa page yesterday and it
says theone layers are six what six not
five or seven who the hell are you i
just wanted to sh that's what nasa says
you can check it out for
your brothers
and sisters and dear friends hope you
guys are doing well before  i start want
praise the most merciful the mosta
there
aci miracles in qur and one of those is
that says there lay whereas you tom was
an athe who was saying hold on a second
mate i know i found out that scientists
are telling us that there's  five oz
layers not seven and why they are arguing
with each other another individual comes
and says he guys i just read the nasa
web website and say no the is a six so
what we going to do is it five six or
seven so as you guys  can see there's a
big problem because the arg with their
and while the atheist is trying to
refute the argument of the muslim he
himself has been refuted by nasa nas
just recently found out that it's six
not five so it shows how limited science
is and how  it changes and one of the
biggest problems is and this is one of
the things i've done myself and this
sketch is basically of a true story
that's happened to me i was speaking to
this atheist and this
this is talking about the oz layer  i
don't have the right to do that and go
out only think that okay you thinking
that is wrong with itself but going out
there propagating is a mistake not the
correct way of doing it the correct way
of doing it is understanding that you do
not get something that is limited that
is changing and use that
tove
and
unlimited what we need understand qur is
not a book of science a book ofs what we
understand from that is that like said
before we we do not look into the quran
our own  understanding just because
science is popular nowadays so we have
to be like oh my go something divine we
need to fit the quran science no we
don't do that we can use science how inr
you upon the creation yes we can use sci
look the cre  and see how work how magn
and
understand worthy of worship and
worship him this is the main point this
is how we can use science but to go out
there and say okay every little thing
that I read oh it says this this might
relate to that  oh scien miracle oh my no
you should not rely on science which is
limited and try to prove to other people
yourself the qur is the truth with that
with something limited that is wrong
another problem that we have is a muslim
would go out look into the  quran and see
that allah says in quran the universe is
expanding then he will go into anas page
and will be saying yes there was a big
bang and all exploded and expanding then
he's going to say okay wci miracle okay but
how about you go to that  same n page a
year later and they go guys we made a
mistake there's no such thing as the big
bang so what are you going to do are you
going to let go the because
limit think
think is reas we do itre and we ching
our way  of approach also i said before
there is many mir linguistic miracle
numerical miracle historical miracle you
can look into other things like i said
before you can use science nobody saying
put science away use science how by
showing people look how the universe
works the order the  system and say look
there must be a creator and he is worthy
of worship so nots in bin say use it
inre so, God willing, you benit bless you May the
peace, mercy and blessings of God be upon you before i
finish i highly recommend you guys to check
this book out please order  it this was
really really help,
God willing, God willing, peace
[music] be
upon you